الكرابل
روسيا بمناسبه عيد الميلاد وفق تقويم
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه القوه الروسيه في كل
الجبهات المواجهه مدعوه بامر الرئاسي الى
وقف اطلاق النار بدا من منتصف نهار الجمعه
حتى منتصف ليله السبت قد لا تعني شيئا
لكيف وحلفائها رفضتها كما كان متوقعا وعلق
عليها بلهجه حاده مستشار الرئيس
الاوكرانيك
روسيا مغادره الاراضي المحتله وعندها فقط
ستنال هدنه مؤقته احتفظوا بالنفاق لانفسكم
ختم تغريدته قبل هذا القرار بساعات قليله
كان الرئيس التركي قد اتصل بنظره الروسي
محاوله اخرى من رجب طيب اردوغان من اجل
جمع الاضداد لانهاء الحرب اكل
الرئاسه التركيه ان دعوات السلام والتفاوض
ينبغي دعمها بيوقف اطلاق نار احاديه
الجانب ابلغه بوتين
مع اوكرانيا شريطه
موسكو المعروفه والاخذ بعين الاعتبار
الواقع الجديد على الارض لاحقا عرض
اردوغان على الرئيس الاوكراني في اتصال
هاتفي التوسط في سلام دائما
مع روسيا بان بوتين يعرض على اوكرانيا تحت
كلمه محدثات الاعتراف بحق روسيا في
الاستلاف على الاراضي الاجنبيه وهذا غير
مقبول كما قال
عيد ميلاد بمراره الحرب وتدعيتها يحل على
المسيحيين الارثوذكس في روسيا واوكرانيا
تقل فرص انهاء الاقتتال والحل الدبلوماسي
وتتدفق الاسلحه الغربيه على قوتك اكثر
فاكثر صلوات الكثيرين يوم العيد ستكون من
اجل من ماتوا ومن بقوا حتى لا يرحلوا في
معركه او قصف